I'm here with Tairi Delgado, who's
one of the course managers here at.
They're the ones who really work one
on one with students to help them
through projects or
help them understand material.
I thank you so much for
talking to me today.
>> Yeah, thanks for inviting me.
>> So
the first thing I wanted to ask you was,
many people have this conception that
online education is very impersonal.
>> Because we're kind of taking
the synchronous in person
communication out of it.
Do you think online education
generally is that impersonal?
>> I think it really is
what you make out of it.
Personally for me, knowing how a lot
of students interact with each other.
I see students connect with each other
through chat, Facebook, LinkedIn.
Getting together in groups.
And I think that kind
of level of interaction
It doesn't have to be impersonal,
it could be something very rewarding.
You can meet somebody from Dubai or
Mexico or China,
somebody that you would never
have a chance to meet before.
And instantly you could have
a connection with something that
you both have a mutual passion for.
When I look at online education,
I think in many ways It
could be a way to learn things
more in a personal way.
Because, at least my experience
when I was in college was that
you would sit in a classroom with 200,
300 people and
it's very hard to talk to your
professor and get one-on-one advice.
I found the most personal experience
you can possibly ever have is a small
group of people that were your friends
that were taking classes together.
You could really get the chance
to work on the problems
are really collaborate with each other.
The next best experience I had was, you
know very few times but you know, when
you had a one on one tutor who really
understood what you were struggling with
and knew the material very well, and
knew how to personalize things for you.
I think online education has
a benefit of doing both.
Because when you're going to these
classes you have the opportunity to
practice on these quizzes at your own
pace, and when you put in your answer,
it's not like somebody's just
marking whether it's right or wrong.
They're actually trying to tell you
specific feedback about what's wrong and
how to actually fix it.
And, you get immediate feedback
to work on and practice it more.
And I think with the ability of getting
groups of people to study together,
I think you don't usually have
that in all, like, settings.
So it's, to be able to have that,
I think,
you know,
can make online education really great.
>> Uh-huh.
So it sounds like you're saying that,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
that there's certain ways that we can do
things online that not only break that
impersonal nature that people think
when they think of online education.
But in many ways make it even actually
more personable because you've
got people talking over the Internet so
they can be available all the time.
They can leave messages and
come back to them later, and
as a result it's not bottled into
this one hour of lecture time, when
we're have a great discussion but now
class is over and we have to move on.
Or you know press has one hour for
office hours a week and
you could go to talk to him then, but
can't ever interact with them on
a regular basis, it sounds like we're
really building in a way to interact
consistently throughout the experience.
>> Right, actually I'll take
it even one step further.
I think the traditional model is, like
you would go talk to your teacher to get
all of the knowledge that you want.
But I think in this age, where we're
constantly learning new things,
and revitalizing our skill sets,
sometimes you just need to
be able to learn new things.
And also facilitate
collaboration with a group of small
people that you would be working with.
So I think this model has changed
more from a teacher directed model of
presenting lectures, more towards this
online content that you can learn.
And then if something
doesn't quite make sense,
you have a group of people that
are willing to support you because
they're trying to
accomplish the same thing.
I think that is a powerful motivator,
having a group of people that you could
interact with and help each other out.
Whereas, instead of always
going to the teacher,
you have a lot more
resources to connect with.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
I think that's especially
the case in our OMS program, and
as well as some of the NST nano-degrees.
That because they're so flexible,
because they're so open, and because
they're so cost effective, we attract
people we wouldn't attract otherwise.
And so, some of the classes
I've worked on in the past,
we've had experiences where someone in
the class is already an expert in their
field in something we're talking about,
and we can basically say, you know,
you don't really need to
listen to us about this.
You've got so-and-so over there,
she's working on a world
class project in robotics.
>> Right.
>> And she knows far more about
this than we do.
And she would never take years off of
her career to go get a Masters degree,
but if she can do it flexibly like this,
she comes and does this, and
then she in turn builds
the class up even more.
Because having her there as a resource,
even if she's just a student in the
class, is incredible for everybody,so.
>> Yeah, the fact that you bring that
up actually cause, we constantly,
at least I know for myself like,
even though like I've
gone through the content I know it
pretty well, there's times when
you're interacting with students you
realize that there's more to learn.
And, like you said, every student
brings their own perspective.
And I think, on top of that, when
we're talking about these study groups
is that, what we tend to
find is that when students
explain things to other students they
tend to learn content even better.
So I think that's one of
the actual benefits that normal
classroom settings don't
really account for.
It's like having a lot of time for
students to help each other out.
Because in the end that's going to be
what's going to drive them the most.
>> Yeah, having that classroom
that's kind of available 24/7 even
though you don't want students to think
they're expected to be there 24/7.
Having it always available
kind of means that
things that we usually have to put
into the set aside time for lectures,
can now just happen organically
over a much longer period of time.
But the conception that online education
is very impersonal doesn't come
from nowhere.
It came from some courses that are done
in a model that makes it very difficult
to feel like you're connected.
So, in theory, we have some students
who are taking this class who
will go on to be instructors for online
classes, or who will go on to be TAs for
other classes at the OMS.
What would you recommend to them for
when there are teaching
classes in the future, making sure
to foster the kind of class that
could develop this community,
this communication between students?
>> Right.
I think that's a really good question.
So I would take a look at what kind of
environment you're trying to set up, and
what incentives that gives.
So, case in point,
I remember when I was back in college, a
lot of times it was greater on a curve.
And so one thing that we noticed
is that a lot of the classes that
were graded on curves didn't really
a foster a lot of sense of community,
because students felt that they
competed with each other rather than
wanting to help each other out.
But in the end it kind of drew back
the ability to learn in general.
Like, I felt like, because you're so
focused on competitive scoring,
you're not willing to take the time
to really learn from somebody else.
And you also want to take a look
into like what motivate students,
like why are they in
the classroom in the first place,
like what what passions they have that
are driving them to take these classes?
Some things that I found when I was
going to classes was that incentivizing,
collaboration with small groups.
Getting students to,
from the very beginning, have
a voice about who they are and why they
are interested in taking this class.
Being able to connect with other people,
so
they can find mutual people in
the class they want to interact with.
And then from there help them setup
some kind of guiding rules that will
allow them throughout the course
to work with each other.
Ohter things that I've noticed is that
you know when professors allowed or
instructors allowed opportunity for
students to kind of play around and
venture on their own a little bit, to
really learn the material on their own.
Really helps a lot for me at least
because you're going to want to
prescribe a lot of quizzes or
homework assignments, and
I think in many ways when I had classes
that I didn't have to, every week submit
like a homework assignment, but rather,
take the time to really focus
on the problem sets and
quizzes and concepts that I felt
that I really needed to study with.
And then studied with my group, well,
people from my study groups
allowed me really to thrive.
I think sometimes homework
could be more, at times,
it feels sometimes like you might be
just doing more work than actually
learning quality material that you
feel like you really need to focus on.
Homework, I felt, was something that
you were supposed to practice on, but
in the end it was something
that you were graded for.
So, like, a lot of times,
it didn't really
Incentivize people to just play around
and just kind of explore a little bit.
I mean, obviously,
you can't expect somebody to know
something the first time around.
Like, what is it to do a linear
regression or maybe how to add a whole
bunch of variables together if you're
learning algebra for the first time.
Sometimes you just need
to practice that and
sometimes students are going to
know what they should focus on.
As long as you give them ideas of
how to be self-sufficient learners.
So, the last component I would make
is that, if you really want to set up
a good learning environment, it's not
only just collaboration and incentives.
But also, how to help students
learn to be self-directed learners.
Like what are the main
ways that people learn,
and what kind of incentives
perform habit over time that
students will want to develop so
that they can always learn new concepts?
>> So it sounds like, really,
what we need to do is make sure we're
leaving room for
students to collaborate.
We're leaving room for
students to learn from failure.
And we're leaving room for
students to learn how to learn.
And those are all things I
think are very real to the way
we learn in the real world.
They don't often, or don't always
make it into the classroom where we
have a very artificial
learning environment.
But generally it's very
important to look at how people
learn naturally when they're not
in the classroom environment.
Their not given homework, or quizzes,
or tests, or anything like that.
But they're just out there learning
from their experiences and
trying to facilitate the same kind
of learning in the classroom.
>> Yeah.
>> So thank you so
much for chatting with me today and
for your insights.
>> Thank you David for inviting me.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
And thank y'all.
>> Thanks.